hey hey good morning everyone good
morning good evening wherever you're
from thank you for joining i'm richie
and we are playing some call of duty
today this is gamespot live call of duty
dropped a new season today so that means
a lot of changes for war zone that means
a lot of changes for
vanguard a lot of quality of life
changes too so
lots of good stuff we might actually be
able to like see and notice uh
warzone has been
you know a little up and down lately so
we're hoping season two will be a nice
little clean break a little clean start
here with some uh big changes let's jump
right in i think i'll just jump right
into a match of
br quads please let me know how the
volume's doing and all that stuff
there's always troubleshooting
i know my voice uh
i like to start off real big like this
but then my voice gets kind of like this
so just keep me in check chat please
thank you all for being here by the way
i see you guys in chat what's up good
morning
let's see if we can get into a match
oh boy
i haven't played um
i like vanguard royale with just the
vanguard guns i haven't played regular
br quads with all the guns in quite a
while so this will be a little
a little rusty for me but i made some
classes i'm ready to go it's so weird to
just see like
you know
a gun from world war world war ii next
to the modern warfare gun but
you know soon enough we will have war
zone 2 and maybe the experience will be
a little more streamlined i don't know
how anyone can keep up with all of this
gun balance it's
simply impossible at this point but
let's see if we can get into a match
here
um so i definitely want to try out some
more zone duh but i want to try out some
vanguard just season two you know there
were new maps also
uh so you know we'll go back and forth
depending on whatever you guys feel also
i'll take that into consideration of
course
good morning
ramses
hey i see you in the chat thank you for
joining just trying to get into a match
it's uh you know day one of season two
so the servers will be a little hot but
here we are
normally for stream i get
some nice
streamer luck some rng luck and we get
into lobbies like pretty okay but you
know
we never know what could happen
anthony hall and chat says hopefully
hopefully warzone does fov for consoles
ah man i hate to be this guy to break it
to you but
this war zone
uh will not have fov on console they
confirmed it the other day
um whatever they're working on next
infinity ward
uh
you know and raven and everyone they
they did mention that warzone 2
might have it or will have it i think
but for now
oh show the battle pass yeah for sure
for sure
uh but yeah sadly i don't think this
iteration of warzone will ever have fov
slider on console oh no sorry i just
showed the battle pass off and like
we're about to start a match
uh but we'll get back to this later this
is you know
oh that's funny there's always something
f in every battle pass like a little key
or something f related
they knew they knew what they did here
let me
meet all the homies here real quick oh
yeah i forgot to put on streamer mode i
don't want any
silly names popping up in my lobbies
here
okay wish me luck i had a one practice
round before
our live stream today
so i'm ready to go i did pretty good too
also they brought um caldera clash which
is the the big team death match on to
caldera
a lot of people
didn't like it if i remember when they
tried that with verdansk um
i'm like i'm back and forth on it
there you go i'm back and forth on it
because um
i i liked verdanz okay and i like the
idea of a big team death match but i
just kept getting sniped like out of the
air it also it like
so quickly became unfun for me but
you know
um probably just a sore loser so here we
are in a regular match of battle royale
just waiting for it to load up
my boy got a haircut oh take jason yeah
uh jason is an old friend gamespot
producer
and uh yeah he knew me when i had hair i
just shaved it all off i think i'm done
with my hair
it's so
zero maintenance is the best maintenance
so i just shaved my head
but yeah thank you jason it's good to
see you thanks for stopping by the
stream man i miss you
i'm just running around here like a
[ __ ]
let's go hopefully my team
will carry me
yes please continue to let me know how
the sound
balances i try not to drop my voice so
low
um
i was telling one of our video producers
jean luke that every time i go on stream
i start off real big but then i get real
quiet so
trying to fix that here we go look at
this goon squad here
all right this guy picked a point
already i'm in
okay so there are lots of there i'm not
lots of there are two new big points of
interest the chemical lab i think
let's see here it was like an f1 or f2
the factory around here
okay we might make our way there
maybe not but
let's just have some fun anyway jumping
down
when is season two coming out it's out
now it just launched this morning
this dude dropped us in the middle of
nowhere
i'm gonna push up a little further oh
there's someone to my right oh
man i don't know about this drop friends
we need somewhere to cover we need to
need a house or something
i'm going to go with green over here
green is not going anywhere either i
think we're kind of doomed
a vehicle
they seriously landed on the mountain
all right i'd rather uh go with them
because we have numbers
at least
at least we have each other at least i'm
not the only target yes
whoa cool blue uh truck here
hope they can make this game enjoyable
again says antonio brown i hope so too
warzone you know at launch was so cool
it was cool for like the first year
and whether whether or not anyone wanted
to admit it i think all the guns and
stuff got cluttered
uh and a lot of things changed to keep
it like competitive and stuff but that's
just what happens hopefully war zone 2
just kind of you know refreshes
everything i like the idea i love the
idea of war zone two like let's just
break away from this
there's also a bomber a new bomber plane
in this uh in
this update
that'd be fun to use
where are we going
what the where's this guy driving us to
see too buddy debating on jumping in any
glitches um there's always glitches
jason in the chat is asking but um right
now this is my first match of the day so
we're going in this together
okay cool i appreciate the honk
objective is to eliminate the bounty
talk what's this
yeah
okay now i need a weapon to freaking use
these i could use my handgun
okay this area looks untouched going in
okay here's some glitches already that
looked funny on the ground
okay
i don't want to use these
rounds on the bar i don't think so
so i do need another gun come on come on
scope
hear a box somewhere
okay same place
let me catch up with my team i always
wander off same in apex same in any
battle royale i'm like just wandering
around looting and then i get killed
first
here we
go a little grease gun
type 100
tough tough you know what i might just
use those rounds on the bar
graphics look nice hey mike thanks for
being here
fingers crossed yeah hopefully nothing
goes wrong last time i streamed
call of duty
i think it just was vanguard we had the
spiky gun glitch which never really went
away but
i think uh
got some help i don't see it as much
anymore thank goodness
that new gun is not the bar oh yeah yeah
wait
yeah what the hell am i holding oh my
goodness gracious
you know what though oh
okay okay okay thank you chat
keeping me honest
you know what maybe
there we go
you know what made it look like the bar
was the barrel or like the
the site at the end there
all right we got reload already dude
there we go the full animation is
complete this is uh
this is the new lmg isn't it i think
prestigious key did a whole video on it
you can do weapon inspects now uh i
think just in vanguard
i'm good i'm good i'm good
yeah thank you chad oh my god i'm
already
mistaken the new gun for the bar
yeah here it is let's have a look
the site is so small
that's cool though it's like precise
it's not too bouncy
what are we doing here friends
oh money here let me
safely give you my money here
i don't have much at all but take it
your box
i already have that
oh shoot
that big that bad dude's trying to
escape us
oh we got trouble way up here
man i pinged incorrectly look at that
but they're up here i see him
just so they know i think they're
actually fighting someone
all
else
yep we got trouble over here folks
can i hit them should i hit them while
they're
should we third party i don't think
anyone's down with me except purple
yeah purple's fighting them off
in a better spot
i don't know how you guys play uh do a
360 noscope says chili flakes no i can't
i can't even snipe dude
uh but that'd be great
where'd they go
i want to be careful okay my team's
moving up i'm just gonna go with them we
gotta load out let's go
although i might keep that new gun i got
to try it out this one right here
let's see okay so i'll keep the new gun
and then replace
this first class i really like
yeah
except i'll switch out
i gotta try the new gun so i'll switch
out the stg for it
and this one has those stopping rounds
there we go
this is so funny just using this modern
gun still haven't gotten over it
do you guys leave the music on like this
i do because it helps with streams like
it's a good audio cue to just have in my
ear
but i used to just turn the music off
all the time i think it helps me for the
most part
okay
aka money man uh no sad money man he has
a little emoji
see here this guy is decked out and all
red gonna get a scene brother
second loadout
damn okay
let's see here
i kind of okay hold on
maybe the a94 instead of the uh as val
well where'd all my crap go here we go
yeah
no i want the a94 okay i gotta get out
of here and take and then take the new
lmg okay we're good we're good second
loadout already and i have like no money
my team is carrying me already
financially
okay well my team is very much like me
they like to post up i feel like
most of the time i'm just the guy kind
of hiding out and then the rest of the
team pushes and
i'm not an aggressive player bottom line
but um
neither is my team so it's gonna be a
little let's see here
stem i have two stims already uh so
let's see here hopefully hopefully it'll
just be a smooth kind of quiet game we
want to explore the map and maybe check
out the new uh factory
get some kills maybe have a little fun
but uh
we're a slow paced group of guys here
that's all
next video games in the chat says
awesome
happy to have you here thank you thank
you for being here
it's a
little too quiet that group uh where
were they
they were northeast over here earlier
but now they're gone
okay i'll move over here with orange i
like this area
maybe i shouldn't hang out in the middle
of the street what
nope not me okay but still someone on my
team
oh shoot we're all getting in the car
let's go
wait for me
oh no
just the one
all right wayne
this car's already got smoke on it
though
dad gamers unite that's very nice
that af while i am dad af with dad bod
i'm not a father
but uh being a dad is more than that
it's just a mood so thanks it's probably
the shaped head huh
man you better not be in school
we are just mobbing look at this
not a care in the world
here's the new area up here it's already
in the in the gas so we can't go but
it's in uh f1 f1 and f2 they said so
the two new areas points of interest are
within that area
am i new to war zone no despite my uh
how it looks no i've been playing
warzone since launch on and off
oh
yeah that's that's a fair point uh joker
in the chat says my movement
uh
appears as if i don't play very much oh
shoot and you're right overall i don't
play very much overall
uh but i get in there sometimes mostly
with friends
as you can see i'm a terrible teammate
i'm shooting
oh no
no no no no
yeah you called it in chat already oh my
god
in general i'm usually always getting
back into it as you can tell
let's see if anything's changed here i
don't think so
unless they already have a new gulag
terrible
your movement seems like you don't play
much yet
just calling it like it is
what's with the new update other than
those two spots um there was some
quality of life changes the biggest one
i remember in the blog update was the
mask
remember how uh when you're shooting
down sight
and uh and your mass comes in when
you're in the in and out of the gas
that's supposed to have been fixed like
finally
there was also
two new weapons
um
and there was uh they called this you
know that
was that gas called
bomber planes are here
that's new the new bomber planes like i
should have tried one of those there's a
new cargo truck in warzone
i already mentioned the weapons um
i'm here on the blog post the blog post
was really thorough
there are these little
bombs found throughout caldera now
but they're really rare
come on how many fights we got to wait
for here
oh man you know what guys i mean it's no
surprise but i'm
i'm
i i don't like the gulag i've always
like freaked out and i swear to god i
always lose
but
looks like we got one survivor on our
team out there i don't know how he made
it but it's money man from earlier in
purple
on the bottom left there what's going on
you know what
if no one dies in 20 seconds i'm out
woohoo
yeah that was a terrible play though
oh a man prepared to fight
come on five seconds
he's going in first let him go first
no there was one second on the clock
ah crap
well
that never happens i think that guy's a
bot he had all those uh okay he's not a
bot but
you know with my luck that's probably
just some kid who's trying to play the
game just like me
okay dropping down on the security point
maybe i can get some stuff before the
gas comes in
holy crap
i'm gonna try to go around try to go
around
oh come on
i had shots on him but i don't know what
he had he had an mp40
did i have an extra plate of armor
either way i lost again oh
oh it's all over we all died okay moving
on
look at this guy sliding around see
that's common
call of duty uh gameplay right there
i never got into like the sliding around
and stuff i'm just not
uh i don't know
i don't know
when i see people playing like that i'm
like i
it's got to make you go faster otherwise
they want to do it or something like
they're
uh oh um that super fast gameplay
like elite i can't do it people are
always sliding around and canceling
slides and jumping and
reload cancelling all that stuff
this game um
chad is a little upset about this game
oh should i play it let's see maybe i
can get a new map of regular vanguard
going
it might be better
gg thanks chili flakes i lost the whole
thing oh look at that bummer oh wait i
know what that means
uh i hate when that happens but uh i'll
just switch over to
the actual game see if it works
there's always a problem with um
ps4 and ps5 versions and i think the
last update on playstation 5 made it
smoother overall but
might just be talking out of my ass
but most of the time it
it it picks the correct version and i
try to get the other version off the
hard drive because that just takes up
room why do they give you the ps4
version on the ps5
whatever ps5 problems
if this happens again though
there we go okay just regular vanguard
let's try
look at the background
yeah happy valentine's day hip hip
hooray
lemon in the chat says i'm halfway there
okay let's see um here we go the new map
let's do a playlist of the new map
my classes
are okay i definitely need to flush them
out a little more
yeah
and keep that the way it is
oh my god look it's raining all these
flower petals these rose petals
anyone else hate these green things up
here
here's the season's battle pass y'all
look at all this winter stuff
you guys that'd be a good question for
you guys do you like you know when the
if you play vanguard multiplayer and
then you get like the mvp
you know you get to vote on the mpv
mvp of the last round do you guys like
that i don't i think it takes up too
much time
and i feel like these little frames are
just another thing to like you know i
don't know add to the battle pass like
key chains or uh charms i mean
a little silly i just kind of want the
game to end when the match is over you
know
but maybe just me some people probably
really enjoy those little animations
they do
mute everybody there
[Laughter]
the hearts around that okay that was
funny
let's see here
just use the mp40
okay we're playing patrol wish me luck i
don't think i have the right class for
this but let's have some fun anyway
someone's already onto me up here
okay too high up
right below us let's go
nice slid right in as soon as that
person was killed
oh no ah the window above
oh my gosh chili flakes i don't have
that answer this morning when i had to
install this update i had to delete um
cold war so i don't have all the
all the games on my console right now oh
i should be going to the control point
but instead i'm running over here
getting killed oh all right
let's just play the objective
crapola
okay maybe i should strategize this here
a little bit
it's a higher ground again
go around
yep someone wants a piece of me over
there
i see them on the roof
that's not a door
this map reminds me of a modern warfare
map actually um i forget what it was
called
uh
oh i'll butcher it but i forget what it
was called um
it's like this outdoor kind of like
town like this is nice
finally got one
oh behind me
dang it i maybe should turn up the um
sensitivity
enter ff in the chat what's up
oh do you have that uh
you have that chrome
extension that tells you the dislikes on
a video i forgot they made that
of course they did
what the all i'm doing you know what
this is why i'm no good at patrol all i
want to do is like lay out whatever i'm
making excuses let's go let's get back
into it look at the score we have to we
have to balance the score here a little
bit
i'll follow this guy
[Music]
do with the right shield
all right where's the patrol there it is
i thought they made it around the corner
wait are they upstairs too someone else
was upstairs okay
should have foreseen that
oh yeah look at this
oh great
that's a really low point oh crap the
bombers
got one
nightmare tyb um
i was just lucky
all this killing me isn't getting me
anywhere i got to go to the control
point
at least it's empty right now i'm going
i'm going i'm going
yeah i should have seen that coming whoa
i got my legs blown off
oh geez
no glide bomb
come on i thought they'd be closer to
the actual circle i tried to run out of
the circle
they were onto me they were on to my
strategy well just getting slaughtered
out here
oh my god all these rounds uh all these
types of ammunition really just
shake up the screen you know
whoa
got one there's always another one
there's always another one
let's see here
oh i saw someone on my left over there
okay he went up oh what up guess he
didn't go up
someone something in the chat says
in modern warfare 3 is this a modern
warfare 3 nope
not that i remember it's a brand new map
wow okay verticality
someone's right above me
just trying to find my way around this
new map
it's very layered it's cool i just gotta
get used to it someone's right in here
watch this
this guy again
i'm still not playing the objective i
apologize
feels good to get some kills back though
at least
going to the capture point
oh oh embarrassing oh
can't say i didn't do anything yeah
that's one thing about playlists i uh
that kind of stinks like it's not always
the game mode you want
okay see like all this like just can we
just end the match that's how i feel
it's way too long
like why is this
why is this still happening it's all out
of focus and everything
oh my god
and this too like um
i think that's the action i have it's
just like the default one look that's me
why am i here most time on the objective
okay
no can we just
can we just move on
there we go
leveling up leveling up the battle pass
i don't have just yet
okay
i like this gun it's a little jumpy
everything i have on it is to like
resist the recoil uh but otherwise i
think it's good i like the fire rate
i love all those valentine's day stuff
in the background
okay maybe one more match of uh you know
this new map oh cool domination okay
so one more match of this and then maybe
some more zone let me guys know or let
me know what you guys want to see in the
chat if anything you know just
call it out if not i'll just go back and
forth i think
69 likes
nice
an achievement for sure
okay here we go gondola i think i'll try
that um
this class out here
oh my god this game's already so flashy
see we're see
[Music]
there goes the gondola
i'm gonna go around
oh this is going backwards though but
cool cave system
shoot right there
oh no look at the game
oh that ended quickly okay
oh shoot my right am i right
i'll tap someone with a grenade maybe i
should just go around for a
i should just use the door oh my god you
can bust open everything
okay
they're taking charlie
that's all we have bro
this dude is meleeing like a madman and
he got me
oh man
well can we take a okay good we have a
oh someone's already here very good very
good as you were
right here watch
come on oh
oh man
i thought i had enough shots on him
again with this guy
hmm maybe go around this way wish me
luck
we can explore the new map together
probably get sniped
i see them
oh come on
what did he have what's the what's looks
like this uh m40 is the way to go
i've been killed by it a million times
today
oh okay it's crowded here
a little thermite here what's my backup
oh no
it's kind of kind of a tough one to
cross
because this open space right here
got one
i think that that was the one that was
bugging me too
maybe not looks he already got knocked
out dang it
they're holding it down at b and c
if you go around again
okay
let me go all the way around
open
so silly god it took forever
you think kicking it down would be
faster but nope
maybe i can do something about b
crapola
okay
taking
i won
see if i can do anything about this
holy crap
that dude with the cowboy hat was right
there i saw these all right cool cool
cool
brick in the chat says game is so bad
tell me brick please just humor me what
was the last call of duty you played
that's a safe space everyone says that
every year but i always wonder i always
want to find out what game
what last call of duty game truly that
you like um
or even like you know
played
i have trouble picking a favorite
ah he had uh plates too
i wonder why this guy's level one
and he has all the stuff
let's see here
oh no oh no oh no
i don't know how i feel about the scope
oh crap
crap wait i'm under this
thing
yes
come on nice i knew there'd be another
way to be
yes oh
no right away as soon as i was done this
guy looks funny look it looks like a
tom some tom clancy character but pink
all right we got a
wait we got a back oh my god
back up to b come on help me out at b
oh
you try the other way
that guy actually went on the gondola
cool oh why am i throwing this
oh no
great
whoa from the spawn really not cool not
cool i wish i had captured the flag
yeah i don't think that ever makes it
onto a playlist like when there's a new
map
um i'm just sitting here getting shot at
uh they they don't include capture the
flag
ever
[Music]
oh they put morris on b
that's where i was trying to go
here we go
yes
whoa no
this guy dude
i don't know how he's still level one
scare the [ __ ] out of me okay
moving on
ooh
[Music]
oh no there's a bad dude
all right the butcher summed it up
pretty nicely he's like this match is
ending no
shoot
there we go
this guy again almost got the last kill
on me
yikes that was rough how did i do
look is this guy again
oh god come on
yikes yikes yikes
that's one of the new battle pass
outfits
okeydoke chat what do you guys say
should i try some more
warzone try maybe try to get one of
those bomber planes
that'd be fun
oh my god you guys want to see me like
flail in a round of solos do they have
solos on day one maybe not but
i did i definitely want to try to get
into a bomber plane
so let's go back to war zone what do you
say what do you say
there it is the new splash screen
this was hard to capture this morning i
had some trouble because it kept wanting
to turn on hdr and that does not go good
with my capture card currently
i'm so glad i got it worked out because
it was like
i could only play on the little source
monitor in obs
it wouldn't properly display on this new
monitor
there we go
the new chemical factory that's right
okay let's see here were there solos no
i don't think so
rebirth is still here here's the new
layout there's clash which is just the
big team death match on a caldera map
which is okay we could try that if you
guys want um
the vanguard royale maybe just br quads
hmm
maybe i'll switch it up with vanguard
royale with with just um vanguard guns
what do you guys think
pr quads do i have a do i have a class
for that like just vanguard i should
yeah i have a few yeah look at that
ah the mp5 ain't
now let's go let's go all the way we got
to do um
just be our quads with all the guns
three consecutive head shots then do the
chicken dance for the fans
maybe the chicken dance but i definitely
cannot get three consecutive head shots
um
but that's okay
hopefully this doesn't take too long
earlier it only took a little bit
yeah here let's let's recap on what's
new um
there's that new gas that's kind of all
over let's see here hold on let me get
that correct
okay so the on top of the new weapons
that have been introduced in season two
i think there's
uh two of them launched today there's
bomber planes the new points of interest
uh are the chemical lab there's also
the armored transport vehicles
um
and then there's that nebula five
there's little nebula five bombs around
the map they're really small and they're
really rare you don't see them very much
according to the blog post
but you have a good chance of finding
them in the chemical factory so we might
try to stop in there
like the research labs are called too
there there's two there's two
new points of interest
but also there was some quality of life
updates
the one i keep bringing up is uh
now when you when you're shooting and
you're aiming down sights and firing in
and out of the gas you know how your
mask always pops on and off and so
annoying i think they finally fixed that
and that was supposed to launch with
season two today
hey hey welcome
baphomet x in the chat what's up just
trying to get a game of quads going
for some reason with the new season it
defaulted to like the old captain price
um
from like modern warfare
2019 it's weird
this wasn't my setup
oh well
hey i'm playing with the guy from donnie
darko
who was his actual name in the movie
i forget
the bunny guy
all right wish me luck
can i do
just use historically accurate weapons
without optical sights or other gubbins
and widgets
man you don't want to see that i mean
i'll pick up ground loot which has
usually doesn't have many attachments at
all
so i'll do that for the first part but
as far as my actual class
i'll need a fighting chance
i'm already i'm really not good at this
game
so someone just fell right in front of
me like this parachute massacre
yeah there will definitely be
plain jane guns on the ground so i'll
use those at first
but trust me um i need all help i can
get
let's do it
they just need to bring verdance back to
be honest says quick scopes
yeah who'd have thought we'd miss that
map huh
although i don't know if you guys saw
on twitter modern warzone the account
asked um
you know the fan account modern war zone
with the news and updates that twitter
account asked
you know which one do you guys like
better for dance car caldera
the result was almost half and half with
with a lot of votes too
i don't know it's very mixed it'll
always be mixed
this guy wants to go here
there's only three of us oh well
i guess i should stick with my team then
all right
this dude drops so fast he's ready he's
determined
but we're not alone oh boy
oh no
sorry to hear about your uh acer
predator
oh crap oh no
it's already hot
i'm freaking out
all we have are our pistols yeah they
see me
i'm toast
they already took this box
oh no
well that other guy landed near me at
least our my other teammate sort of no
he's all the way over there i should
have gone with orange
now i'm out here exposed
i hear a box
though there
oh what the [ __ ] it was so low there we
go
something
see where they're at they were around
here
okay meeting up with orange
so open oh my goodness yeah so was
verdansk
maybe that's the thing though they'll
just keep adding
more points of interest
i do like how colorful this map is
though compared to verdansk
i like the green
i wish this were like in apex legends
where you can slide down and build
momentum and just keep sliding faster
and faster
it was great really worked for some like
sometimes it was like a strategy
especially if you have like octane or
something
i miss that game
all right i am just blindly following my
friends here
or my teammates
there we go
hey speaking of apex legends these
things
are here now too that you can uh like
redeploy using those
simon west says caldera is a better map
it's unplayable for console players ooh
that's interesting verdance worked once
they fixed the circles a bit should all
be good
that's interesting i am it's it's a it's
a
it's kind of a double up situation for
me because i am a console player
and like
i'm not you know like elite or anything
uh so that's why i always i was telling
the chat earlier
the teams like by default usually when i
squad up with randoms they usually just
accidentally tend to carry me i'm
usually just quietly looting and like
hanging low and then um
uh
get one or two kills if i'm lucky but
i really wanted to check out the map for
us today to see the the new points of
interest and try to i wanted to get the
um
that new bomber plane
but no one wants to land there i might
have to just go on my own next time
anyway let's have some fun
oh a box
i think i'll keep this
it's nice to have the scope
hmm anyone want this sniper rifle
this place hasn't been
looted through yet i don't think so
i could definitely use that
perfect
okay gotta stay close to my friends here
or my teammates
playing with some randoms this sucks
though i jumped into a quad match and
sometimes it just gives you three people
total that's what happened
huh
there's the new lmg
why not i didn't get to use it last time
because i died so early
how do i have no money wow
at least i have weapons
wow this guy already got the loadout
great
here we go
mlg tactics no this isn't the
uh war zone 2 was announced by infinity
ward last week
oh shoot
uh but this is not it this is just
season 2
of call of duty vanguard
someone is definitely here they just
landed
stupid bush there we go our stupid palm
tree
hopefully my team picks him up
man yeah this dude was on me
everyone's level one i think that's like
a oh the season just started that's why
duh of course everyone's level one
prestiging ain't what it used to be
that's all
yeah simon west is correct in the chat
here we go
through the wall maybe nope
terrible terrible back and forth there
oh it was the last guy no
okay this time i'll try um
going straight to the chemical factory
oh man yeah this whole game is just full
of
uninstalling and up
and uh updates
this morning i had a delete cold war uh
entirely just to make room for this
update
vanguard for you yeah this and then i'll
try um
yo should i try solos yeah try solos
just so i can have some peace and go to
the
chemical plant actually
there definitely won't be peace there
but at least we'll be able to see it
okay
all vanguard
that one's okay
see what i can do here
man this one has all the attachments so
does this one
no no it's missing two
okay that might be a good base oh no i
haven't
purchased this what am i doing
the nail gun oh my goodness
maybe just another
are one was good too
i don't even know if i have much
unlocked for this one yet
hit buyer sprints
solos okay let's see how this goes
search and deploy there it is
there's a new chemical factory the green
smoke oh man
inside there they're supposed to be um
what was it nebula 5 ammo and bombs
little bombs
what's up you guys hank hello how's your
day doing good so far not a bad day when
you start with some call of duty
um
james in the chat how much do you play
i'm on and off with this game um
i really was
not having verdansk for a while uh so
but i've been back and forth especially
since caldera has entered
definitely dipping my toe back in
but uh as you can see just probably just
by how i play
not elite here nothing like that just
having some fun just trying to see the
new
map
okay this one's oh here we go is that
the bomber can i jump into this one
probably not
so used to playing gta
hostile dropping into the
hip hip area
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
oh it's night here cool hank where are
you from
right now
on the west coast
it is 11 a.m that means i have half hour
left
okay let's try at the factory
okay maybe just outside of the factory
so i can like sneak into the factory
around here ish
it's paid agents
we might all be trying to go to the
factory that's the thing
you're from europe cool
well thanks for being here
um some things were added today and a
lot of things were added in season two
of
call of duty vanguard and warzone so
appreciate you being here we're trying
to have some fun and
check out the new factory straight ahead
the new factory and um maybe the new
weapons i picked one up but i still
haven't been able to kill someone with
it yet
yeah i totally neglected my drop point
over there but whatever maybe you can
just go into the factory it didn't seem
that crowded
oh there yeah there's one guy i saw like
maybe three people total head this way
crash right into the wall
george the jungle style
let's see here let's see what's going on
cluster strike yes absolutely
hmm
wait volkswagen there
the volk
well here we are
oh okay they tell you that now
you hear anything
sometimes i've been picked off from that
little window right there
armor satchel should i go with that um
nah i don't think so
maybe hey look
um maybe i should get the f out of here
wait
here's someone
i hear someone i hear someone if they're
on the roof i'm just gonna do this now
because i got another one oh it's a uav
okay
the sights on this gun
well i didn't get anyone
here we go
okay there's someone there's a yeah kind
of surrounded let's see here there's
someone right here
there's one
i moved because i knew everyone would
start seeing me from there he's over
here somewhere i went too far okay
man i was just picking off that guy
do not want to be sniped to filth here
oh yeah this guy was around here
somewhere i see him
right that is not a person
wow
here's footsteps oh crap
okay so he's on the roof that's why i
tried to use that strike earlier no luck
i released the gas earlier i don't know
what it did or if it hurt anybody
got to be careful
this person is right above me for sure
can i do it again
[Laughter]
crap crap crap
watch this
oh
what a relief
cool he had a bunch of stuff
should really get good at this
i gotta move the gas is coming kind of
soon
oh this is what i did look at this
okay cool that's kind of cool
now i'm scared to move though how far
along is the gas
oh i'm fine here for a little bit i
might post up here this is a
it's kind of cool i haven't been here
just yet
maybe that one too no
people are going to be coming up from
behind me too this will be a little
scary to move up
solos is totally different game do you
guys play solos very much when you play
battle royale i usually don't but
i am
wanted to explore this in peace without
my team hassling me
is the gas op
always
so many uh
so many of these supply boxes everywhere
i only got one kill oh yeah that guy
earlier i didn't kill actually around
here
let me exit downstairs or you know what
the roof
that's too risky i'm gonna go down
somehow
okay
actually yeah well why not i have an
open slot for this
and the molotov
okay now the gas is a serious problem
here i go
go go go go go go
oh wow i might have blown it all the way
look at this
oh
i should have tested the the shooting
out
yeah i'm totally screwed you guys well
that's obvious
ah
i had so much good inventory too like i
finally got a bunch of stuff i probably
had enough money for a loadout
that's true last time i played solos and
for dansk it was really campy i got
lucky i got second but i was camping out
too
so maybe it doesn't bring out the best
of us
although
people say you know camping is just a
strategy especially when you're all
alone
anyway here i am
in the gulag
return to the front again okay at least
it's not an lmg this time
come on buddy boy
right here watch
should have stammed oh god you're right
i had those sims i picked up
60th what a disgrace
rip yeah thank you emma
mlg tactics
rip
okay we got another 20 minutes folks
maybe some more vanguard if you guys
want to see the uh
the new maps that were added for this
season
they have a playlist going so if you
guys want to see that let me know or if
you want me to just try some more um we
haven't tried uh caldera clash yet just
the big tdm
should have stemmed would have survived
yeah absolutely well maybe i still like
despite every advantage you can give me
i'll screw it up somehow
uh let's just see how this goes this
isn't my favorite mode
uh
but i want to see
how caldera is used in tdm big tdm
last time when this happened in verdansk
i just kept getting sniped like straight
out of the air plunder please
i don't know i'm no good at plunder
f in the chat
thank you
yeah
drop all of your f's please
all right
well yeah um
i tried plunder
i think a total of like like under a
dozen times i think total
it used to be good uh sadly it used to
be good for just kind of exploring
around the map and i say sadly because
people actually want to play plunder
uh the mode itself is okay
but uh i never got into it like it was
easy to like get a bunch of money
because i love to loot in these kind of
games but
um i don't know
it wasn't it wasn't for me
team deathmatch but warzone yeah it's
it's team deathmatch on the caldera map
if i ever get into this lobby i'll show
you it's it's like a bunch of players
just on both sides of um like a small
section of caldera
i wonder if you can use any gun you want
though
that's the that's the second time i've
seen the donnie darko bunny costume
maybe it's the same guy from earlier
here you go yeah these are all
this is what you do in uh uh caldera
clash
oh yeah they have power ups
i think i remember those in the
verdance had that like war mode which i
really liked
oh cool i can use any gun
let's go with this first class
okay
i think we're just about ready
practice is over practice is over
it's better on overkill says james
mlg says gamespot really getting mileage
out of the gun expert react series oh
yeah everyone loves uh
jonathan ferguson you know
it's a great series
let's see
i'm pretty getting shot out of this guy
yeah
you know
that was very that was two gta of me i'm
gonna move on and not do that again
although that was fun and it's just like
team deathmatch so guess what just come
right back in
but i did waste a plane that was kind of
a dick move
here we go
okay
what am i doing no way
screw
kind of takes the pressure off when you
just respawn uh maybe i will like this
match or maybe i will like this game
mode
oh shoot
it's crazy seeing jigsaw on the same
building as like a
real soldier here let me see okay
paper airplanes
that's no ac-130 that's true
although they added the
was it the ball turret in to vanguard
this season
i don't know how i got that kill you see
how scattered my gun was
what's on the other side of this fence
oh i have a stem
wow wow wow wow
i could use another plate
why oh my bullets are blue i don't think
i even meant to do that
oh their tracer bullets from this um i
think i'm using a special
the groza unlocked what the heck
oh
crapola
oh i'm on fire
the guy okay that guy's pretty cool he's
using uh john mcclane from die hard
oh yeah there's time to respawn it's
interesting
tdm war not ground war it is not ground
war that's correct there are no
objectives other than to kill people
uh so it's not the same thing it's kind
of a mix
okay what do we got
wait i thought i heard a box
whoa here we go this is one of the
little speed boost tokens this will
probably get me killed but this is what
it looks like
whoa look at it season two better or
worse hopefully better just for the long
run they've implemented some
quality of life changes that i think we
can all appreciate plus there's new
points of interest so
season one was pretty rocky
um i think for
for vanguard so hopefully season two is
just smoother overall
hopefully
right now as it stands right now the way
i'm just like playing as is oh [ __ ] bad
guy
i think
oh someone below me it's a friendly okay
oh the new uh the new nebula five rounds
cool let's test these out
uh overall i think i'm hopeful for
season two um i can't say if it's better
just yet it's only day one
but thanks for your question
okay i definitely gotta try out these
rounds there we go
looks like the action's over here
oh geez
another one oh man
combat bow wow this was a very giving
care package
wow okay let me ping this for someone
else
i'm doing all this preparing but
someone's gonna run up on me soon and
just take it all away from me they're
gonna kill me
see what i mean i had all this good
stuff and i looked at that dude right in
the face there we go right there
they should just ban me from this game
you know what though like i said the
pressure's off because i guess i guess i
get to just respawn again
here i am
okay he's gone
same
i still forgot i had stim that was a
terrible gunfight mm-hmm
ooh does zombies mode get something new
i think i saw something on the uh
you know the road map for this season
good question
i think they do but i'm not sure when it
comes you know some some things some
updates come mid-season and for zombies
i forget if it's at launch or mid-season
but stuff is coming i would check the um
the call of duty blog
or you know if you give me a second here
after this match i'll tell you exactly
what's up
okay they got him great skirt
cool okay moving on
you know what whatever let's go in
keeping it low oh look at this
that'd be so funny if i shot him out of
the sky like that
which you can totally do
cool airplane assist
whoa
i've been playing a lot of gta 5
recently just getting back into online
those controls for driving i think are
so good
um as you can see i don't have it here
gotta hook up mouse and keyboard warm up
playing with aim hero target mode for
three hours and chug adderall like a
true pro mlg tactics i think these are
your mlg tactics
um i am
already bad enough as it is on
controller
i don't think i'll be switching to pc
mouse and keyboard
it's so um i've tried to go back for
years
because you really do have the advantage
i think
uh but i can't get into it
i used to play pc games when i was
pretty small and then like
after uh consoles became popular
nah i'm keeping this one
whoa
holy crap
are you welcome what a 901 in the chat
yeah they're definitely gonna add some
zombie stuff this season i just forget
when
all right
turbo cps man
ah man we're losing again for a while we
were up by like not that much
overall though let's see if we can get
the
oh look at the bottom there it says
two times two times
friendly friendly oh someone's over here
though
i should get out of the line of sight
i'm freaking out here look at the
the surrounding of my screen keep saying
times two when i clearly don't deserve
it
got one
i don't need a speed boost right now
hmm
oh crap
no no no no
whoa that slide lasted way too long
i don't have any more
okay cool despite how that looked i
still have all my plates i'm good
they're all gonna be right here watch i
get up here no
i'm tilting my head like this like in
real life like it'll help me
that door yeah they're gonna shoot their
way through that door
okay there were like three of them there
david says i've never played cod in my
life that's cool man
what games do you like
by the way thanks for being here if you
don't play cod and you're still watching
the
stream is this fun um it's okay this
this mode specifically like this clash
mode
is okay it's just a big tdm
like i'm all right with it
someone was down here
oh friendly okay
whoa
[Music]
why not
where is he
threatnull nice
oh great i just got in this thing oh
well
oh i never played god
oh that person was just posted up with
it ready to go
are you pro no god no
that's uh
sorry david no i'm not
but we're just having some fun i think
when this match ends we will wrap it up
someone's up there let's see if i can
get him oh he's already dead okay
whoa super slide
oh
clever
whatever that was oh
one plate left
defeated rats can i still kill that guy
no i can't aim down sights or anything
that's funny they treat it like
warzone i got second but out of two
that's so silly okay
let me switch it over here friends
bam thank you guys for joining me uh
season two is out now across all
platforms so i hope you get a chance to
download and play for yourself but in
the meantime thanks for being here and
i'll see you guys next time
signing off see ya
you